>> Laura: I HAVE A LITTLE RING
THAT THEY GAVE ME LAST NIGHT.
IT IS THE MONDAY BEFORE
ASH WEDNESDAY.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
50TH ANNIVERSARY RENDEZVOUS,
WATCHING MORE THAN 30 FLOATS AND
MARCHING BANDS COMING INTO THE
CONVENTION CENTER AT
NEW ORLEANS.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE, ONE OF THE
SERIAL EXPERIENCES THAT YOU
REALLY HAVE TO SEE.
HE FOUND ANOTHER CREW DEDICATED
TO HONORING OUR VETERANS AND
TRANSFORMING THEIR LIVES.
WATCH.
♫ ♫
>> IN NEW ORLEANS, ALONG THE
MISSISSIPPI, A PREPARADE A PARTY
IS UNDERWAY.
THESE ARE MEMBERS OF A
MARDI GRAS GROUP.
THE HOST PARADES AND UNDERTAKE
PHILANTHROPIC WORKS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR.
THEY WERE FOUNDED UP BY A GROUP
OF LAWYERS FROM NEW ORLEANS.
HE WAS ONE OF THEM.
>> A FEW OF US HAVE RETURNED
FROM ACTIVE DUTY OF SERVING, AND
THERE WERE NO CRUISE AROUND THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY HONOR JUST A
MILITARY.
AND WITH SO MANY PEOPLE SERVING
OVERSEAS, WE WANTED TO HAVE FUN,
BUT WE WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
THAT WOULD HONOR THE MILITARY.
A FALLEN SOLDIER, WOUNDED
WARRIORS, SO MANY THINGS.
>> THE ORGANIZATION ROLLING
THROUGH THE USE OF STREETS.
THIS ONLY ONE, DEDICATED IT TO
CELEBRATING AND POPULATED BY
VETERANS.
>> AS HE CAN SEE, RAIN OR SHINE,
THEY ARE ROLLING.
A LITTLE RAN COULD NOT STOP THIS
CREW.
MANY OF THE WRITERS HAVE SEEN
COMBAT IN IRAQ, AFGHANISTAN, AND
VIETNAM.
FOR SOME, IT IS NOT JUST A
PARADE, BUT AN EXPERIENCE OF JOY
AND HEALING.
FRED AND BILL SERVED IN VIETNAM
TOGETHER, BUT IT WAS THE LEGION
OF MOBS THAT REUNITED THEM AND
TO CHANGE THEM THE BETTER.
>> EVERYONE KNOWS HOW WE WERE
TREATED AND ALL OF THAT STUFF,
PTSD, SO MY WIFE’S THOUGHTS THAT
IT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA FOR ME,
PERSONALLY, TO JOIN A GROUP THAT
WAS CATERING TO VETS.
AND IT HAS.
IT HAS BEEN A BLESSING.
IT HAS KIND OF BROUGHT ME OUT OF
MY SHELL, GAVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET FOLKS.
AND I FEEL A LOT MORE
COMFORTABLE BEING AROUND
VETERANS.
AND ACTIVE MILITARY, SO WE NOT